one of the things that HBO has done so
well in the past is reinvent tired
genres fantasy is one of the most
successful genres there is but no one's
ever done it the HBO way these books are
very adult fare it's it's fantasy done
for adults this is a story that's so
rich and there's so many characters so
many different viewpoints and narratives
all working together with incredible
expertise it's a story where everybody
is pursuing their own interest and
everybody is following their own code
and this provides a much much richer
story than the guys in white feeding the
guys in black the entire series is fused
with a sense of magic but there's very
little onstage magic and I love the way
that's handled I think too much magic
can ruin a fantasy I was much more
interested in the people I just find it
fascinating how he's created this world
is totally different world which kind of
works in every level George Martin is
the creator of this world and came to
set a couple weeks ago he said it's like
walking into one of my dreams it was
this incredible moment of my god they've
got it right there it is the majority of
my fans are gonna be very happy because
they're gonna see the story that I told
come alive played by some fantastic
actors Sean Bean Peter Dinklage Lena
Headey kids our cast is just astonishing
it has a certain Flair about it that
elements of fantasy and air playfulness
which sets it apart from from anything
else we've seen before I've not really
seen anything like this